[Music]
bili Eilish is opening up about her love
life like never before I'm so excited
knocking forward to it the Grammy winner
covers the July August issue of British
GQ and inside the mag the 18 year old
gets candid about her not so great
experience in the dating world quote
here's a bomb for you I have never felt
desired my past boyfriends never made me
feel desired none of them Billy adds
that it's a big thing in her life that
she has never been physically desired by
someone and Billy who is known for
wearing baggy outfits says it's played a
part in her fashion choices sometimes I
dress like a boy sometimes I dress like
a swaggy girl and sometimes I feel
trapped by this persona that I have
created because sometimes I think people
view me not as a woman
well Billy may feel boxed in now I like
to be judged so I wanna I want to see
head back in 2019
she told et she wanted to turn heads
with her style choices it's really sick
it's kind of exactly what I'd want
people to care about you know yeah like
I don't know the things that people sort
of know me for are all the things I want
to be known for if that makes
style has always been something I care
about but back to Billy and love the
ocean eyes singer told the mag she's
never felt powerful in a relationship
and the one time she did she took
advantage of that person's kindness
because she wasn't used to it if I think
too hard I get all up in my head so
don't ever think it now she tells the
mad quote it's been months and I am not
attracted to people anymore
I don't know what's going on it's
actually kind of dope Billy also opened
up about fame admitting she knows she's
clickbait quote the thing I realized
recently is this when you get to a
certain level of fame or notoriety it
doesn't matter what you say or do you
are a certain level of known you will be
super hated and super loved I think it's
so weird when people think they're gonna
be huge god that's so weird I never in a
million years would've thought this
would happen like I'm only grateful for
it for real
[Music]